hi guys it's been a while since I scared
myself on this channel so I found this
game called the house abandoned which
seems pretty cool because it's an indie
game it's actually a text adventure but
it's psychological horror and it's made
by a team from the designer of alien
isolation seems interesting let's see
how this goes music yes it's inspired by
very like retro old kind of text
adventure games but it is a horror game
don't worry
yeah we'll see on this case I think it's
gonna be get interactive horror
adventure see told you
you pull up to the driveway of the
family holiday home and park the car
it's dark but it's as idyllic as you
remember from all that time again you
remember being told to check the glove
box before going in it's good to be back
oh oh gay gay gay so hey take things in
right yes text adventure okay yeah I
understand this so what do I do
I I guess I check the glove box so cool
I'm actually typing inside is a key and
a handwritten note from dad you take
breaks reads the note the note is from
your dad and beads
- I'm again it's fine hope you enjoy
your break you'll need to fire up the
generator around the back to get power
and lights on also found something in
the Attic for you the Attic it's in your
room enjoy press any key to continue
okie dokie you're sitting in the car
parked in the driveway you have taken a
note and key from the glove box
I'm sitting in the car turn on the radio
I'm sorry I don't understand drive away
I've got to try it tonight come on I'm
gonna try and not follow the story fine
fine fine you have taken a new Anki okay
use the key to get in the house what
fine yeah fine fine get out of the car
get up get out of the car
hey you get out of the car and stretch
your legs
the house is grand it's not perfectly
amongst the trees in front of you is the
front door and the yard stretches around
the back of the house
go to the yard you walk around to the
yard you spent a lot of time with here
with your family on holiday trips good
memories burn stuff that's what I do in
yards I'm sorry I did fine no don't do
that the weird way I had a family who
had a farm who had a yard and we would
burn stuff in the yard okay um go inside
and see house or maybe unlock the door
oh yeah you go back around to the front
of the house yeah I know that the house
is grand it's pretty unlock
you rinse at the key and ten the door
clicks open and then then and into the
house you enter the house to the hallway
it's dark and you can't see anything you
feel a light switch next to the door
however well turn on the light that's
always a good thing in a horror movie
you know you don't want to be sat around
in the dark use the light switch I'm not
using the right terminology z' hear a
click and nothing there is no power the
note should say how to restore it oh yes
right so meet where's the generator
again
oh it's around the back isn't it ok wait
we've the note again because I forgot ok
go to the yard leave the house
go to the yard read the note okay hey
what in the olden days did keyboards
have little cassette tape players in
them because that's pretty cool one of
those right now please
what's this you'll need to fire up the
generator around the back okay so find
let's find the generator go go to your
next to the generator you use the
generator usage switch the generator on
and it wears to life the house still
dark okay but when he is okay because we
need to turn the light switch okay go
back around to the house and that house
is gland we know this enter the house to
the hallway yeah yeah use the light edge
you switch the lights on no always now
brightly lit there's access to the
kitchen and living room here as well as
the set of stairs going up well we know
that dad's after something on the bed
but I'm hungry so let's go to the
kitchen you go into the kitchen the
kitchen is tidy and well-kept there's a
door to a utility room but otherwise
it's just a kitchen go to the fridge
no that's not how you spell fridge
the proteges get some food go to the
utility the utility room door is locked
hmm okay go to the hallway let's go
upstairs
bored you go back to the hallway okay
and then go up stairs you make your way
upstairs the stairwell landing there's a
bathroom and two bedrooms yours
and your sisters victors adorn the walls
images of happy times look at the images
no the pictures
family photos and holiday snaps our
happy family okay go to my bedroom let's
see what our dad's left on the bed for
us you go into your bedroom you enter
your old bedroom so many good memories
in here and it's been preserved so well
on the desk is a gift-wrapped box Oh
open the gift wrapped box you open the
present excitedly you can't believe it
dad has found your old computer he
wrapped up a complete like an old
computer on a huge a future oh one to 8k
plus two it's been preserved well in the
Attic and hopefully still works let's
use the computer you untangle the cables
and set up the computer the computer is
all set up and ready to go there's a
game here too what game is it
play the game you put the cassette in
the computer and press play shite nah
why did I scream that wasn't even scary
didn't expect anything to happen around
the outside screen I'm confused
dafuq you pull up to the driveway at the
family-owned boom ah I'm sorry again
wait what is this like a game in a game
am i playing the game in the game
because it says here you put the
cassette in the computer and you press
play yeah oh wait no this is totally
different like it's dark but it's
clearly neglected you remember being
told to check the glove box before going
in this is like a dark other side of the
game okay and the times changed it's
midnight now how to midnight guides
right listen let's carry on
umm check the glove box there's a note
and a key ok read the name
it's probably not gonna be a nice little
for my dad you don't recognize the
handwriting
it says get out get out get out get out
get out get out the car get out the car
get out the car get out get out get out
get you were sat slumped in the car you
have a note clutched in one hand and a
key in the other you need to get out but
you don't really want to
drive away sorry I don't understand
hide and cry okay oh okay right get out
of the car you reluctantly exit the car
the house looks abandoned
there's a yard to the side Wood creaks
in the wind and all happy memories are
gone from this place there is no love
here so I'm guessing we probably need to
go to the generator again as go to the
yard you step through the debris to the
backyard the grass is overgrown and
weeds crawl up the side of the house
it's not a nice place to be
you clutch the note needing to look
around look for the is there a generator
or am I just like expecting that feel
useful use
is the generator oh wow it turned on
what the far it's turning into real life
like I might see in the house look at
these pictures they will blacked out now
it's not nice and friendly like it was
before there wasn't much fuel but the
generator starts up then you okay
go to the house again okay I thought
it's just turned off again how can it
take someone to be so freakin scary I
guess because you're not just playing
the text eventually like you're actually
in the thing
unlock the door you unlock the door the
click of the lock hurts to hear open
it's black but your senses are punished
more why the smell stale air and damn
this could not be less inviting the note
burns in your hands you feel compelled
to read it over and over the message has
changed hasn't it okay
read the name come on it's too dark to
read but it feels weird to the touch
again is there a light switch you switch
the light on but wished you hadn't the
lights flicker on and off the walls are
falling apart after years someone else
is in this house that can't be hi
make it stop make it stop make it stop
make it stop
house [ __ ] stop somehow the alarm stops
you can feel the panic sets in you are
still in the hallway the noise has
stopped but you feel a presence someone
is in the house they should not be here
there is a kitchen and a living room
adjacent and stairs leading up the note
feels disgusting in your hands too much
for me it's been too long ok it says
nine nine nine nine nine that's not even
a time okay hmm
read the name I can't read the note it's
bleeding it's a note is fading okay
let's discard us a note because I don't
think I need this bloody note in my
hands this scart of the night they
probably won't understand what that
means though no let's go to the living
room you enter the living room
the living room although hardly an
appropriate term
the furniture is threadbare and borne
the note is fixed in your mind dread
fills the pits of your stomach
this is not a nice place why does he
keep on referring to the note we didn't
know again this is still just bloody the
note always changing now reads get
through this I don't care if you want to
or not not even a helpful though that's
not even helpful okay
sit on this sofa let's just wait through
this all to blow over now you return to
the boy you're still in the boy should
we just go back upstairs again right I
think it wants us to go upstairs let's
go upstairs go upstairs
you head up the stairs to where the
noise came from same but different the
landing has acted before behind the
Drakh phone starts to ring you don't
understand neither can he neither can he
what as in the person in the freaking
the house okay pick up the phone I can't
hear what you're saying
over that venue answer the freaking
phone you hear him answer the phone your
mind hurts and you taste iron voices
spill out of the phone into the water
whoever is in there should not be there
you need to hang up the phone
I do whoever you consider the worst
someone's behind the door
someone's behind the door the door that
will was it up with the exception of
your room you have to get in the
pictures are different from before the
note trembles the guilts is overwhelming
the guilts what did you freaking do in
this summer house I'm a murder and I I'm
a murderer and I did he kill his family
oh right let's get through this let's
read the name the note is now clean
again simply reading get in get out you
have to go through with it
still not helpful name then you are not
helpful in the slightest you haven't
said anything just already gout the car
go through with it and get thing get out
okay let's look at the pictures then
look at the pictures
the pictures are of your family the eyes
have been scored at yeah just like these
ones here so the eyes have been scored
out on all brilliant kiss them okay
enter sister's room no that's not that's
not a word
Jennifer's room is boarded up you can't
bear this wait so which one's the doors
are all poor love with the exception of
your okay right so enter my wingman the
door is bolted shut with a four-digit
combination lock
two four six eight
no it's two four six eight the PT number
I don't know to give it is but it's
probably not okay so it's go back
downstairs let's go into the kitchen oh
I can't spell downstairs go down you're
back downstairs you're still in the
hallway the noise has stuff to put those
of prisoners in the house
can I call out their presence in the
house shall we do that does they always
do that in horror movies and it's always
so stupid like they shouldn't do that
but they always do that anymore hello
who's here
call out
nah doesn't understand I asked who is
there doesn't understand like that okay
go to the kitchen you go into the
kitchen the kitchen stinks and feels
completely unfamiliar the tabletops a
rusted metal and there is a carcass oh
there's writing on the wall and the
utility room door has a red X painted on
it
okay that's let's read the writing on
the wall I will know what carcass is on
the thingy as well read the writing come
on
wait the wall you can't tell me there's
writing on the wall and then nocturnal
is what the hell what can't I read the
writing on the wall
you look closer but can't tell what it
is or what it was really
now you are disappointed in yourself for
even going there
Oh game disappointed me for trying to
eat the carcass go to the utility the
door is locked
something tells you that's a good thing
I want to read the writing
fine read the note the paper now feels
like fabric it's covered in blood you
can just make out the words there is
nothing for you here oh really
something for me here okay yeah we're
gonna we gonna read this writing I just
gotta find the right the right words to
say because it's not read the writing
it's not read the wall it's not looking
at the writing it's not look at the wall
it's maybe like look around the number
of 1986 one nine eight what the [ __ ] do
you mean Jesus I'm so jumpy tonight what
is wrong with me I crossed the wall in
what looks like blood okay that's cool
right well let's go back to the hallway
and remember that one nine eight six one
nine eight six you get this oh there you
go it's right on the wall brilliant at
least I won't forget it
thanks game yay
I'm just a no really jumpy mood I'm wimp
1 986 986 you're still in the hallway
the nines have stopped but you feel yeah
I know there's a presence in the house
and I need to get into my room and
someone was on the phone and I don't
know what's happening right let me go
upstairs please
I hope you guys know as creeped out as I
am because this is a text game I just I
didn't think it would actually be that
scary I don't think it guy would be
screaming someone is bomb in the door
yeah I know stop at the all for noises
gosh I'm getting goose bumps okay I
think there's something about knowing
that you're playing a game where you're
playing a game on the computer and
you're actually on the computer that
freaks me out because it's like I can
believe does that make sense I don't
know it just makes it scarier go to my
room okay one nine eight six
what
okay you grab the log the log is Rusted
not used in years the key in your hand
weighs heavy then no to heavier you drop
the log and can now input the code okay
now we put the code one nine eight six
the lock clicks open and someone is
behind the door the doors are all
boarded up
let's open the door find out who's
behind and say hi would you like some
food I have carcass downstairs open my
door
I'm in the room hi I'm in the I'm in the
room no I don't like this freaking weird
hi huh
if I if I couldn't already see what's
behind me in the camera I would have
actually turned around ooh
okay um say hello
give the person a hug
and to the room go on then
you enter the bedroom it feels utterly
familiar the walls are damp but you've
been here before
in front of you a lone person sits in
front of a computer screen the lamp is
on the clock reads 9999 you shouldn't be
here I shouldn't be here you grip the
note tight what is no 999 it's not a
time okay
reason though I am controlling you buddy
you might be behind me but I'm
controlling you I'm sorry Jonathan I'm
sorry mum I'm sorry dad
you haunts every step I take even in
this place it was out of my hands but
still you punish me I can be with you
now what I keep thinking that that phone
cord is like a noose so he didn't kill
them but something happened to them that
he couldn't stop there was nothing left
to do
I'm consumed and confused this has to
end now
well I don't know
talk to the person
never talk to me talk to me but it don't
change the subject
you know what you have to do there is
nothing enough to do what do I have to
do okay
unplug the freaking game
don't kill me though you don't have to
kill me do you do you don't kill me
talked I've already done that um leave
the house is that what you have to do I
don't know what you gotta do
I don't know though I don't know though
I'm crying when I keep on making Zuzu
scared
um turn on the light no I think you have
to kill me why are you killing me though
fine confess confess but I don't think
you're a killer why would you kill me
you were saying that you couldn't help
your mom and sister and dad not that you
killed them maybe you are are you a
killer
totem did you like you're the person
behind me um fine fine
kill kill
oh you are pathetic it was all your
fault say it I am a wonderful person oh
please stop it was all my fault
say it
you're stupid just say it
give me a hug just say my say yeah it
was oh my
finally
for like quite a short game and such a
simple concept that was really pretty
good and really scary I don't know what
you guys are scared as I was I don't
know you've got to been watching this on
a computer in a dark room sat in front
of a desk and then you get the full
experience because you're watching
someone be on a computer at a desk and
it's kind of like you just feel like
you're actually there and it's really
creepy I would love to see more people
play around this kind of concept it
works so well
yeah jump scares still though didn't
really appreciate those scary give this
the thumbs up if you enjoyed it's been a
while since I played our game so I
really hope you did enjoy this yeah I
think I got adequately scared for you to
be entertained so you're welcome
have a lovely day or evening bye my
sister saved me from becoming dinner
yeah it is Hansel and Gretel try to stay
calm in peace Jesus say you need to stay
calm you can down later calm then you'll
find the subconscious will call itself -
then the game starts getting freaky if
you freak out basically these are the
little breadcrumbs